[Musique]
j'aime créer et du coup l'idée était
surtout pourquoi à la Réunion on n'avait
pas nos assiettes
les Bretons ont leur bol et nous et est
important d'avoir nos assiettes
[Musique]
la Réunion est tellement belle que oui
il faut la dessiner et puis d'un point
de vue culinaire aussi donc les
assiettes à l'intérieur on peut avoir
déjà le dessin du caribolaï dans
l'assiette en illustration en fait on
mange dans une illustration
[Musique]
j'avais une voisine qui qui pratiquait
et j'ai demandé si elle voulait bien
m'accorder quelques quelques moments
pour m'expliquer comment ça fonctionnait
donc je n'ai eu que trois matinées en
tout et pour tout j'ai acheté un four je
me suis lancée toute seule en fait
depuis toute petite depuis que j'ai tenu
un stylo j'ai toujours dessiné et du
coup le dessin m'a permis il m'a soutenu
et m'a permis de d'évacuer énormément de
choses
[Musique]
comme nous vivons dans une société qui
est très dur qui est très difficile et
que chaque jour est un combat et ben je
mets des musiques de louange et je peins
c'est une passion mais la poterie à la
fois ça peut être aussi une thérapie
ça m'a permis plus je voyais que les
choses étaient difficiles et plus
justement les dessins devenaient
beaucoup plus beau bizarrement
[Musique]